okay so welcome to this webinar
i'm jen wartman vaughan senior principal
researcher here at
microsoft research in new york city and
part of the fate research group here at
msr
today i'm going to be talking about
transparency and intelligibility
throughout the machine learning life
cycle i'll also be doing a live q a
session after this talk
so if you're watching this initial
broadcast live
please feel free to submit your
questions at any time
all right so if you've found this
webinar
i don't think i need to waste time
convincing you that machine learning
is important but throughout this talk
i'm going to be arguing for the
importance of taking a human-centered
view of machine learning
we often think about machine learning as
this fully automated process
we take some data use it to learn a
model
and outcome our automated predictions
but one thing that i've learned over the
years is that people are at the heart of
the machine learning life cycle
people define the task that machine
learning is going to be used to solve
people decide what data to collect they
decide
how to clean and pre-process the data
and how to label it
and the data itself is often generated
by people either
explicitly for example through
crowdsourcing or
implicitly for example if the data
contains
text written by people or images of
people
people determine what model to use say
a neural network or a decision tree or a
linear model
people choose how to train this model
how to test the model
which may again require gathering more
data from additional people
people make choices about whether where
and how to deploy this model
and of course deployed models end up
impacting people's lives
sometimes in high stakes domains like
medicine or finance
finally feedback from these people is
incorporated as the model evolves
given the central role that people play
in the machine learning life cycle
i take the position that building
machine learning systems that are
reliable
trustworthy and fair requires relevant
stakeholders
to have at least a basic understanding
of how they work
this view is reflected in microsoft's
core principle of transparency
one of our six ai principles and it's
something that i think about a lot
personally as the co-chair of
microsoft's ether working group on
intelligibility and explanation
this working group is part of our
broader ether
efforts on programs policies procedures
and best practices
on issues to do with ai people and
society
but you might ask what exactly is
transparency
well okay people use this term
transparency in
all sorts of different ways and i'm not
going to attempt to end this debate
once and for all right here so let me
just tell you
what i mean when i talk about
transparency
i find it really useful to break
transparency into three components
this breakdown is adapted from one that
was proposed by the european
commission's high level experts group on
ai last year and i like this breakdown a
lot
so first of all transparency relies on a
foundation
of traceability this means that teams
should clearly
document their goals definitions and
design choices and
any assumptions that they've made now i
happen to be someone who gets very
excited about documentation
and i know that not everybody out there
shares this excitement with me
but i still want to take a few minutes
to talk about traceability
because i think it's really important
i'm going to start with data because
data plays such a central role in the
machine learning
life cycle and the machine learning
models that we build
about two years ago a group of us at
microsoft research in new york
started a project called data sheets for
data sets
inspired by data sheets for electronic
components
we propose that every data set be
accompanied by a data sheet that
documents
relevant information about the data sets
creation
its intended uses its limitations and so
on
data sheets can help data set creators
uncover
possible sources of bias in their data
or unintentional assumptions that
they've made
they can help data set consumers figure
out whether
a data set is right for their needs
whether it will be useful for a model
that they're trying to build
and if exposed either in whole or
in parts to end users they can help end
users figure out
how much they should trust a system
so we've been piloting data sheets
across microsoft
and from early pilots we've updated our
idea
of the types of questions that
a data sheet should include and you can
find a full list of the questions that
we recommend
in our paper on this topic we've got
questions on the motivation
for a data set it's composition the
collection process
any pre-processing or cleaning or
labeling of the data
the intended uses of the data and
perhaps uses that it should not be used
for
the distribution of the data and also
maintenance
questions about ethical and legal
considerations are peppered throughout
all of these sections
we've also constructed a new proposed
workflow
so that each of these sets of questions
can be answered
at a specific different phase of the
data sets life cycle
now there are actually a huge number of
research challenges that have come up
during our pilots and i'm going to
mention just a few
so some are to do with the specific
questions that we ask
for example how should these questions
be modified
when the data set that we're looking at
consists of
streaming data instead of static data
there are also a lot of questions around
workflows and incentives
but one thing that we've learned along
the way is there's not going to be a one
size
fits all solution here and different
teams are going to need to modify this
type of proposal to fit their own needs
but given the central role that data
plays in machine learning
the payoff for getting this right we
think is potentially huge
in parallel to these internal efforts at
microsoft we're collaborating with the
partnership on ai
which is a multi-stakeholder institution
that's dedicated to studying and
promoting best practices for ai
last spring the partnership launched a
project called about ml
which is dedicated to applying
transparency to all components of the
machine learning life cycle
to make this happen the project is
building off of data sheets for data
sets as well as other related proposals
like
the data nutrition project at mit
google's model cards and ibm's fact
sheets
so one way that all of you can get
involved is to create your own data
sheets when you release data sets online
we've actually started seeing some
awesome examples of researchers
including a data sheet as part of a
paper either as an appendix
or maybe through a separate link and i
would love to see this become a
community standard so
please help us make this happen
okay moving on the second component of
transparency
is communication those who build and use
ai systems
should be forthcoming about when why
and how they chose to build and deploy
these systems
as well as the system's limitations
data sheets are of course relevant here
too if you think about how they might be
tailored
to help this third population of
stakeholders the end users of a system
another way that we're thinking about
implementing communication at microsoft
is through what we call transparency
notes
so for example last spring microsoft
released a transparency note
for our face recognition api
this is this publicly available document
that details face api's
capabilities and limitations it includes
a discussion of how users
should interpret different accuracy
measures like false positives and false
negatives
and some examples of how a team might
try
to might choose to trade off these
accuracy measures against each other in
different applications
this is also related to things like
model cards and fact sheets
and it's also something that academics
who are releasing machine learning tools
might implement as well so i encourage
you to think about
i encourage people to think about things
like this more
okay finally the third component of
transparency
and the one that i'm going to spend the
most time on in this talk
is intelligibility intelligibility
means that people should be able to
understand monitor
and respond to the technical behavior of
ai systems
to whatever extent necessary to meet
their specific goals
this is um sometimes referred to in the
machine learning community
as interpretability um and
the european commission which i
mentioned before
refers to it as explainability i've
actually used the phrase
interpretability
a lot in my own work including some of
the papers that i'm going to talk about
today
but for the rest of this talk i'm going
to stick with the term intelligibility
personally i like this term the best
because
it has roots in the hci community and
to me at least it kind of emphasizes
that we're talking about a
human-centered concept here
right something can't really be
intelligible without being intelligible
to someone
so why should we care about
intelligibility well
there are a whole bunch of different
stakeholders of machine learning systems
that can benefit from it
so let me just give a handful of
examples
so intelligibility can improve the
robustness of an ai system
by making it easier for data scientists
and engineers to identify and fix
bugs and i'll come back to this
particular use case later
intelligibility can help doctors or ceos
or any other decision makers using a
system
decide when and how much to trust this
and hopefully this will eventually lead
to better outcomes
intelligibility allows designers to
reason about how
systems and models behave so that they
can appropriately convey this
information to end users
intelligibility around key
characteristics
of a data set that's used to train a
model
can potentially uncover sources of bias
or unfairness in the data
that will make their way into the model
intelligibility can help demonstrate
compliance with regulatory
obligations so things like gdpr
potentially
intelligibility enables new tools to
help scientists who are developing
models
make hypotheses about their world
and just generally intelligibility leads
to more usable
products
so the approaches to model
intelligibility that are coming out of
the machine learning community
generally fall into two categories
the first type of approach is to design
and deploy models that are intuitively
simple so simple here might mean
something like a small decision tree
or sparse linear model for example
my colleague dan goldstein and his
collaborative collaborators have some
really nice work
on simple point systems that a decision
maker such as a judge
could potentially memorize and apply on
the fly without even a need for pencil
and paper and
they actually show that perhaps
surprisingly
in many high-stakes domains at least
those where we're talking about
tabular data these point systems are
nearly as accurate as more complex
models like neural networks
so there's no loss there
as another example rich caruana
has a body of work on generalized
additive models or
gams that falls into the same category
the reason that gams are nice is that
their predictions have
this additive structure which allows
users to visualize the impact
of a single feature so you have one
function that's corresponding to each
feature and you can visualize that
function
in order to see how the feature is
affecting your output
remember this because i'm going to come
back and talk more about gams a little
bit later
all right so the second common approach
in the machine learning literature
is to design simple post-hoc
explanations for complex models
so you may have heard of lime or shap
and
these would fall into this category so
many of these approaches
work by approximating a complex function
using some sort of simple local
approximation
like a linear function that can be
easily explained
shop which i'm also going to come back
to later in this talk
builds on ideas from cooperative game
theory to just
assign an importance to each feature
which
you can think of intuitively as a
measure of
how much that particular feature
contributes to
a prediction for that particular data
point
if you're interested in playing around
with some of these approaches i'll give
a quick
shout out here to the interpret ml open
source package
which was released by some of my
colleagues at microsoft earlier this
year
and i'll mention that azure ml also
offers similar functionality so those
are both great resources to look at
but despite all of this really cool
research that's going on
and these tools that are being built
there's actually
still a fair amount of disagreement in
the machine learning community
about what intelligibility actually
means
and how to measure it looking at all of
these proposed approaches
it's really natural to ask what makes a
model
or an explanation simple and
how is simplicity related to
intelligibility
and do these models actually help users
achieve their goals
so there have been a couple of position
papers examining this
issue over the past couple of years and
as finale doshi velez and bean kim
points out in theirs
the machine learning community all often
has this
you'll know it when you see it type of
attitude around intelligibility
the difficulty of defining and
quantifying
intelligibility is compounded by the
fact
that there are different stakeholders
out there
and these different stakeholders or
users have different
needs the approach that works best for
a ceo who's making a strategic decision
is likely to be different from the
approach that works best for a regulator
who wants to understand why an
individual is denied alone
and this in turn may be very different
from
what a data scientist needs when they're
trying to debug a model
on top of all of this all of the
approaches that i've mentioned so far
have focused on intelligibility
of the model itself but if you think
about
this bigger picture of the machine
learning life cycle that i mentioned
earlier
model intelligibility is just one piece
of this bigger picture
depending on who our stakeholders are
and what goals these particular
stakeholders have
we may want to introduce intelligibility
at other stages of the machine learning
life cycle
starting from the definition of the
problem or task
that is being solved through data
collection and
all the way to intelligibility around
model deployments and feedback
so these concerns have prompted me to
adopt
a human-centered agenda for intelligible
machine learning
and i should tell you here that i am a
learning theorist by training so it has
taken me a
long time to get to this point in my
career
um my colleague hannah wallach and i
have actually written a
book chapter on this which should
hopefully be online by the time you're
watching this webinar so i would
encourage you to check this out if
you're interested in
kind of more detail on how we envision
this
but within our research group we've been
working on this agenda from several
angles
so first of all we propose that people
stop relying on intuition and instead
empirically test which factors of a
model
enable users to better achieve their
goals and in a few moments i'm going to
tell you a little bit about some work we
have in this space
that examines how factors commonly
thought to influence
intelligibility actually impact people's
use of a model
a second angle to consider here is
intelligibility beyond the model so
for example intelligibility of data or
intelligibility of objectives or
performance metrics
and i'll tell you about some work that
we have in the space examining how the
stated and observed
accuracy of a model impacts people's
trust which we view
as a study on intelligibility of
performance metrics
finally we propose that people design
and evaluate methods for achieving
intelligibility
in context with the relevant
stakeholders
and here i'll tell you some more about
some very recent work examining
how data scientists perceive and use
intelligibility tools
okay so jumping right into this
first point to question our intuition
about intelligibility and empirically
test this intuition my colleagues and i
found it helpful
to think about intelligibility as a
latent property
that can be influenced by different
manipulable factors
such as the number of features of a
model whether the model is linear
the user interface of the model whether
the internals are exposed and so on
and that in turn impacts different
measurable
outcomes so things like a user's trust
in the model how willing they are to
follow a model their ability to debug
the model or perhaps their ability to
simulate the model
now notice that all of these properties
on the left here are properties of
system design
whereas on the right we have properties
of human behavior
so taking a cue from psychology
to study this we designed randomized
human subject
experiments to isolate and measure the
impact
of these different system factors on
fundamental properties of human behavior
that are pertinent to intelligibility
so the idea is basically to randomly
vary
these factors like the ones on the left
and then
measure their impact on human properties
like the ones on the right
while this may sound like it's something
that is very
simple to do in practice it's really
hard
to do this while holding all other
factors of a model
equal and this is kind of the
contribution of our way of thinking
about this
so in our first set of experiments on
this topic
participants were asked to make
predictions about the
selling price of different apartments
with the help of a model
so in addition to a simple baseline
where participants didn't actually have
access to a model at all
we considered four experimental
conditions in a two by two design
and these are corresponding to the four
models that you see here
so i don't expect you to be able to read
everything on these slides but let me
point out the differences between these
conditions
so first the models on top make use of
only
two features while the models on the
bottom make use of
all available features
additionally the models on the left are
presented
as a black box with no information about
what the model is actually doing
while on the right you see transparent
linear regression models with weights
that are visible to participants
and for these prediction for these
conditions on the right
we explain during a training phase
exactly how these models
work to make sure that participants
understand
now crucially in all of these conditions
participants see the same model input
so everyone sees exactly the same
features of these apartments
they also see the same model output or
predictions
so that is we specifically chose a set
of apartments where the two feature and
eight feature models that we are using
made the same predictions this means
that
the only difference between these
randomized conditions
and what people see is what's in between
so if we observe any differences between
these conditions
we can safely attribute these
differences
to the model and what we're showing them
so this is kind of super important in
our design
so i'm not going to go through our
studies in detail but i just want to
mention a few
key results from this study and some of
our some of the implications of these
results and i'll point you at our paper
if you're interested in learning more
so first we found that participants who
were shown
this clear model with a small number of
features two features in this case
we're best able to simulate the model's
predictions
so this is perhaps unsurprising but it's
reassuring to see this
play out in the data from our experiment
however we found no improvements
in the degree to which participants
followed the model's predictions on
typical examples when it generally
actually would have been in their best
interest to follow the model
additionally we found that in some cases
too much transparency can actually be
harmful
so specifically we found that
transparency reduced people's ability
to detect when a model is making a
sizable mistake
and correct for this mistake seemingly
due to information
overload so this was really surprising
for us and um did not kind of match our
intuition about what was going to happen
here
and the popular belief in the machine
learning community
the more generally these results just
emphasize
the importance of user testing and
experimentation
over reliance on intuition alone in the
design and
evaluation of intelligible models
okay moving on to the second direction
intelligibility beyond the model let me
briefly describe some work of ours that
appeared in chi
this past year that can be viewed as a
study of intelligibility of performance
metrics
so in this study we set out to examine
whether a model's
stated accuracy on held out data affects
people's trust
if so whether it continues to do so
after people
have had a chance to observe the model's
accuracy in practice
and finally how a model's observed
accuracy
in practice affects trust
to do this we again made use of
randomized human subject experiments
we showed subjects um information about
pairs of people who had been matched
together through a speed dating event
and we asked them to predict whether
these people were interested
in seeing each other again based on this
data that we presented them with
in particular subjects were asked to
make their own predictions
about whether a particular speed dating
participant
wanted to see this particular partner
again
so they were then shown a prediction
from the model
after making their own prediction and
were given the chance to
revise their prediction in light of what
the model said
so they did this many times completing
40 such tasks
in two phases so at the beginning of the
first phase
we gave them information about the
model's accuracy
on held out data
then after the first phase which
consisted of 20 of these
tasks we gave them feedback on how
they themselves and the model had
performed
so far so they got information about
both their own performance and the
model's performance on the first 20
tasks
and at the end we had them answer a
couple of questions
about their use of the model
um in each of our experiments here we
varied
either the stated accuracy of the model
which we told them at the beginning
or the observed accuracy
of the model on the first 20 tasks
or some combination of the two
okay so again i'm going to just skip
right to the high level results and
implications
and point you at this paper if you want
to learn more
so first we found that the model's
stated accuracy on
held out data does affect people's trust
in the model and
specifically they are more willing to
depend
on the model when its stated accuracy is
higher
we also found that people put
substantial weight on their own
interactions with the model in the
accuracy that they observe
we saw this happen even though the
subjects in this experiment
had somewhat limited interaction with
the model
that is they changed their behavior
after getting information about the
model's performance in phase one
which only contained these 20 tasks
so these and other results that we also
discussed in our paper
really highlight the need for designers
of machine learning systems to clearly
and responsibly
communicate their expectations about
model performance
we see here that this information that's
communicated to users
really shapes the extent to which they
trust a model
both before and after they observe the
model's performance
in practice so it's important to get
this right
okay so moving on to the final
bullet here
i'll spend the next few minutes talking
about some very recent research
looking at how we can evaluate the
intelligibility of existing tools
with stakeholders in context
this work was led by an incredible
summer intern harman kaur
and depending on exactly when you view
this webinar
and say that there's about a 90 chance
that you should be able to find our
paper online
so in this work we're zooming in
specifically
on data scientists who are building
models
as our stakeholders of interest
in particular we're interested in
looking at
how data scientists use
and perceive existing off-the-shelf
intelligibility tools we're interested
in the challenges that they face in
doing this
and we're interested in the
opportunities that we
as the research community have to make
these tools better
so before i get into the details of our
study i want to take a step back
and talk for a little bit about why this
type of evaluation is challenging
and i want to be really super clear here
that
the reason that this type of evaluation
is often missing
from machine learning papers is not
because machine learning
researchers are lazy or just don't care
but because getting this type of
evaluation right
is really a research agenda on its own
and not something that's trivial
so first of all doing this right
requires expertise
in both the details of the machine
learning
models and intelligibility tools as well
as expertise in hci
or psychology or other human centered
fields
it requires knowledge of both the
academic literature
on these tools as well as the day-to-day
engineering practices
of data scientists
it requires both a qualitative analysis
that's useful for understanding the
nuances of how people use these tools in
context
as well as quantitative methods so that
we can
yield more reliable and scalable
findings
a good study here should mimic realistic
data analysis
settings yet it can't be too cumbersome
for example
in this work we were trying to limit
ourselves to a study that people could
complete in one hour
and finally it requires being able to
separate
effects from of the model from effects
of
the intelligibility technique that's
used
from effects of the user interface of
the specific tool
and these are things that can be really
challenging to tease apart
so this is not something that it's
generally easy to do
we tried as best as we could to address
these challenges
although no study here is going to be
perfect
so first to address these challenges we
recruited
a diverse team to work on this project
consisting of both a mix of machine
learning
and hci researchers as well as data
scientists who actually
have day-to-day experience both building
and
using intelligibility tools
we also attempted as best as we were
able to
put the data scientists that we studied
into a somewhat realistic context which
i'll tell you more about shortly
and finally we did apply a mix of
qualitative and quantitative methods
so specifically we started with
pilot interviews which we use to
qualitatively identify challenges that
are faced by data scientists in their
day-to-day work
we then performed a contextual inquiry
which you can think of as a
structured interview in context to
observe data scientists ability to use
these tools when faced with the
challenges that we identified
this again was a purely qualitative
analysis
and finally in order to scale up these
results we ran
a large scale survey with around 200
participants
which we designed to try to mimic the
contextual inquiry as best as we could
okay so to reiterate our goal here
was to evaluate data scientists use of
existing intelligibility tools to
address their day-to-day
challenges of building and evaluating
machine learning models
so our first step then must be to
understand the types of challenges that
data scientists face
or the context in which they're going to
use these intelligibility tools
this was the goal of our pilot
interviews
from these pilot interviews we extracted
six common challenges
so missing values in the data redundant
features
duplicate data that's masked as unique
temporal changes in the data ad hoc
categorization of feature values
and challenges recognizing
patterns that will help with debugging
i'll come back to some of these in a
moment
building on these challenges we designed
a contextual inquiry
which again is essentially a structured
interview
in which we try to place participants
into context
in this case working with real data a
real model
and a real intelligibility tool
we wanted to explore the use of both of
these
types of approaches that i mentioned
earlier
so both simple models and post hoc
explanations
so we chose one example of each
and had half of our participants using
generalized additive models or gams
and half of our participants using shap
the post-hoc explanation technique
we began the contextual inquiry with a
pre-study interview
about the data scientists prior
experience and expertise
before moving on to the main study and
ended with
a series of follow-up questions
for this study participants were given a
jupiter notebook
that we had already set up for them
they first saw a tutorial on the
intelligibility tool that they were
going to be shown
which is based on existing published
documentation
with a bit more detail that we added
ourselves
we then saw an introduction to the data
set
which was a modified version of the
popular adult income data i'll talk
about how we modified it in a moment
um they saw a little bit about the model
and were given a chance to play with
some of the models visualizations
and they were then asked a series of
questions
about the data in the model
so each of these tools gams and shop
provided three types of explanations
the first is local feature importance so
this is a description
of how important each feature is for
the prediction that's made on a specific
individual data point
the second is global feature importance
so how important
is each feature on the whole across the
entire data set
and these actually look very similar for
the two approaches
the third type of visualization zoomed
in on the way that a specific feature
so age in this example impacts
predictions
so as i mentioned before we use this
modified version
of the adult's income data set
specifically
we modified it to reflect the types of
challenges
that we extracted from participants
during the pilot study
so for example data scientists often
face
problems due to missing values in the
data and the way that these missing
values are filled in
so before training the model on 10
of the data points where the label was
positive
which in this case means that the
person represented by the data point
makes more than a certain amount of
money
we removed the age value and
used the common approach of replacing it
with the mean
across all of the data set which in this
case was 38
and this resulted in the model
exhibiting this strange
jump in predictions for 38 year olds
as another example to capture ad hoc
feature categorization we took one
feature which is the number of hours
that someone works in a week
and binge the values into these somewhat
nonsensical categories of zero to 30
hours
30 to 60 hours 60 to 90 hours and 90
plus hours
so most of the data points fell into
this 30 to 60 hour bucket
okay so a couple of different themes
emerged from our qualitative analysis of
the interview data
from this contextual inquiry
first of all we found that there's a set
of participants who
overuse the tools using them to justify
cases where the model
exhibited strange behavior and this
led them to place too much trust in the
underlying machine learning model
so as one participant who was given gams
said
age 38 seems to have the highest
positive
influence on income based on the plot
not sure why but i guess if that's
what's shown
makes sense
another participant who has given shop
ran some of their own tests and was
willing to
accept the model's behavior when this
participant
found that their own test agreed with
shaq's output
saying test of means says the same thing
as shop about age
all's good
on the flip side we saw some cases in
which participants
underused the tools because they weren't
confident about
exactly what the tool was showing them
so as one example
a participant who saw shep said the tool
assigned
assigns a quantity that is important to
know but it's showing that in a way that
makes you misinterpret that value
now i want to go back and check all of
my answers
after going back and playing around with
the data some more
the participant continued okay so it's
not showing me a whole lot more than
what i can infer on my own
now i'm thinking is this an
interpretability tool
another theme that emerged was the
importance of social context
so in particular participants seemed
willing to trust what the
intelligibility tools were telling them
because they were publicly available
tools and they said this very explicitly
so one participant said i guess this is
a publicly available tool
must be doing something right i think it
makes sense
and another said i didn't fully grasp
what chat values were
this is a pretty popular tool and i get
the log odds concept in general
i figured they were showing shot values
for a reason maybe it's easier to judge
relationships using log odds instead of
predicted value
anyway so it made sense i suppose
okay so we thought these qualitative
results were
super interesting and a bit worrisome
but we wanted to scale up our findings
so we designed a survey
to attempt to replicate the cont
the contextual inquiry setting at scale
as best as we were able
the survey began with some questions
about demographics and experience just
as the contextual inquiry did
and then since participants would not be
able to interact
directly with the jupiter notebook
anymore
we showed them screenshots of common
ways in which the contextual inquiry
participants had chosen to explore the
data set model and tools so we tried to
kind of
simulate this interaction even though
it's not perfect
finally we asked them a bunch of
questions about the data set
model and tool that they were supposed
to answer
based on screenshots of visualizations
that we showed them
we took advantage here of having a
larger pool of participants to run
some randomized controlled experiments
in our survey as well
so we randomized two things first
as before we randomized whether a
participant would use
generalized additive models or shop
and second in order to understand how
people were affected by the
contents of the explanations
we randomly showed half of our
participants a manipulated version
of the global feature importance values
instead of the actual
visualization
so in particular on the left here we
have
the global feature importance plot that
would be shown
to participants in the normal condition
on the right here we have the plot that
is shown to participants in the
manipulated condition
this is identical except we've swapped
around
the order of the features here so which
feature corresponds to which bar
with the results that the unimportant
features are shown
as important and the important features
are shown as not important
so our qualitative findings on the whole
were similar to what we saw
in the contextual inquiry though some
additional themes
emerged so for example
even though we showed tutorials very few
participants could
accurately describe the visualizations
beyond a superficial level
when we directly asked them what the
visualizations were showing
so by a superficial level i mean some
would say something
like feature importance but not give any
any detail on what feature importance
actually means
we also saw that participants often use
these visualizations to craft their own
narratives
in order to convince themselves that the
model was reasonable
so for example one said plot b looks
reasonable since it provides a bonus to
individuals
in working age range and penalizes
others it also correctly considers
widowed people to be more likely to earn
more since they are more likely to
inherit assets um
so this is not really what's going on
here but people crafted their own
narrative
um about what they thought the
underlying model might be reflecting
um and again we're kind of seeing here
that some participants
seem to actually increase their trust in
the underlying model just because
they're being shown
an explanation right we would hope and
said that people seeing this explanation
would become
suspicious of the underlying model but
that's not what's happening
um so in our paper we explore all of
this qualitative data much more if
you're interested
but i want to mention some of our
quantitative comparisons now
so in particular we pre-registered eight
different
quantitative comparisons that we wanted
to make between these different
randomized experimental conditions
so for three of these we did see
significant differences between
participants who saw gams and
participants who shall shop
specifically participants who use gams
had higher accuracy on the multiple
choice questions they were asked
about the visualizations that they saw
they also had higher self-reported
confidence
in their own understanding of these
visualizations
and participants who saw gams had a
lower
cognitive burden as measured by
a standard nasa tlx cognitive load index
so putting these three results together
this is kind of all
evidence that participants found gams
somewhat easier to use than shop
the results for self-reported confidence
that the model was reasonable
are actually very reassuring
so here we saw that people who saw the
unmanipulated or normal version of
gams were more confident that the model
was reasonable
than people who saw the version with
manipulated manipulations
sorry manipulated visualizations um and
the same was true
for shop so this is good because it
tells us that
people are paying attention to the
actual content of these explanations
at least to some degree um we also found
that people who saw the
manipulated version of shop were more
confident that the underlying model was
reasonable than people who saw the
manipulated version
of gams so this is kind of further
evidence that
gams may be easier to work with in some
sense than chap people were
more able to recognize that something
a little bit fishy was going on with
this visualization
however for the other four quantities
that we looked at
self-reported confidence that the
explanations were reasonable
the extent to which participants rated
the model
as ready for deployment whether people
expressed
suspicions about the model and whether
people express any suspicions about the
intelligibility tool itself
we saw no significant difference between
conditions at all
so we saw no difference between gams and
shop here
we also saw no difference between people
who saw
the normal visualizations versus people
who saw the manipulated visualizations
so this work suggests several next steps
for the research community that i'd like
to highlight here
first we really need more interaction
between
machine learning and hci researchers and
we need this interaction to be happening
much earlier at
earlier stages human-centered approaches
should be incorporated into the design
and the development
of these intelligibility tools in the
first place in addition to
their evaluation
second we need more tools that are
designed
specifically to encourage deep thinking
and
discourage people from making snap
judgments
actually one of our study participants
put it really nicely
saying there's this concept in ux called
thinking fast and slow
while these visualizations made me think
fast every detail about them
requires that i think slow
finally in our study as i mentioned
before we are aiming for each
participant to only have to spend about
an hour
engaging with the tool and really the
community
is going to need more longer-term
studies
in order to explore how uh
people's understanding and usage of
intelligibility tools changes
over time as they become more
comfortable about the tools and
learn whether to trust them and when and
how to use them
topping up a level i told you about
studies that we've run
on lay people and studies that we've run
on data scientists
but there are many other stakeholders
out there
who might require intelligibility and
one really huge wide open direction in
the space is to better understand the
needs of these stakeholders
and how to design intelligibility
approaches to help them
and finally as i've been arguing
throughout this talk
we need to take a broader view of
intelligibility
and think about how to bring
intelligibility and transparency more
generally
to every stage of the machine learning
life cycle
all right so thank you all so much for
watching this webinar and i hope that
you found it useful
if you're watching the initial broadcast
i look forward to taking your questions
in the live q a session that's about to
start
um and you can check my website for
links to many of the papers that i
mentioned
during this talk if you're interested in
learning more so thank you again
okay hi everyone so thanks so much for
attending the webinar today and thanks
especially to everyone who submitted
questions
i'm jenn wartman bond you've just been
listening to me speak for the last
52 minutes or so but um now i'm here
live to answer a couple of questions
so let's jump right into that okay
so our first question today is one that
i get asked a lot
and it's more of a personal question
so as i mentioned briefly my background
is in machine learning theory
and algorithmic economics which are very
theoretical mathy
areas so how did i end up incorporating
all of these techniques
from hci and other human centered fields
into my work so this is a great question
so often in academia and in research
just because of the way that incentives
work around hiring and around tenure and
all of that
people end up getting boxed into one
specific
research area or one specific
methodology
and sticking with it the thing i've done
in recent years that's led to the
biggest
impact on my career and on my own
satisfaction
with my research is to kind of smash
that box apart
so i can trace my interest in human
factors back to a specific panel
discussion i attended back in 2016.
it was one of these panels on ai and
society that are happening all the time
now
and one of us one of the panelists made
this comment that stuck with me
he said and here i'm going to paraphrase
a bit soon our ai systems will be
so good that all of the uncertainty will
be taken out of our decision making
and i heard this and thought wait what
the world is inherently full of
uncertainty
all of our ai systems and machine
learning models have uncertainty baked
into them whether it's explicit or not
to me it just seems totally
irresponsible to tell people
that ai could take uncertainty away
so i came back to new york fuming about
this comment
this was around the time that there
started to be a lot of talk about
democratizing ai
making it easy for lay people to build
or deploy their own machine learning
systems
uh for context it was also around the
time that hillary clinton's chance of
winning the u.s election recovering
around 80 percent and the general public
was
treating this as a done deal and
watching all of this play out and
replaying this panelist quote over and
over in my mind i became obsessed with
the question
of how well people really understand the
predictions coming out of models
as a theorist i was trained to always
state my assumptions
clearly and explicitly and this is
something that i thought about a lot
i was afraid that people may not always
understand the implications
of the assumptions that go into machine
learning models or the uncertainty
behind any prediction
these worries led me to discover um
this literature that was just starting
to come out of the machine learning
community
on intelligible or interpretable machine
learning some of which i mentioned
in my talk a few minutes ago and i got
really hung up on the fact that people
were designing these methods without
stopping to define
exactly what they mean by
interpretability or intelligibility
basically proposing solutions without
first stopping to define the problem
that they were trying to solve
so we started talking about this problem
with colleagues with backgrounds in
psychology and computational social
science and other human centric fields
and we decided to do something about it
since then i've gotten more and more
passionate about these issues and i've
also started working in the space of
fairness a lot more so fairness is
another area where it's crucial to
consider
the humans who are involved and the more
that i get involved in this line of work
the more it seems to be the case that
the problems i'm most excited about
are not problems that i can address with
theoretical models or with new
algorithms alone
there are the problems for which i
really need to use human centered
techniques
so solving these problems means that i
have to kind of
break out of my box i just have no
choice if i want to do this work
and i've been having a great time doing
it um by the way one approach that's
worked really well for me here
is hiring research interns who have
expertise in
running user studies and conducting
interviews and all of this methodology
that's outside my own formal training
so i'm always looking actively for phd
candidates in the space who have
training in hci or psychology or other
related fields and are interested in
collaborating with machine learning
researchers
so if that is you please drop me a line
okay let's see the next question i have
here that i want to answer
is about data sheets model cards
and other related documentation based
approaches
so i very briefly mentioned that um
incentives can be an issue here so
in general um busy people aren't
motivated to spend a lot of time on
documentation
so what can we do about this
uh this is definitely one of the biggest
challenges
around making processes like data sheets
and model cards the norms
and actually i think this issue of
incentives and priorities is something
that goes beyond documentation
to processes around responsible ai more
broadly
so i have an upcoming chi paper with
michael madeo luke stark and hannah
wallach in which we looked at checklists
for fairness in ai
and in particular went through the
process of co-designing
an ai fairness checklist with machine
learning and ai practitioners in
industry
so during this process we uncovered some
organizational challenges that
practitioners face
that would influence their ability to
adopt checklists
and i think these challenges are very
similar to those that come up when we're
talking about adopting data sheets or
model cards or any of these approaches
so for example participants in our study
who came from a variety of different
companies
felt as these types of process that in
order for these types of processes to
succeed
it was crucial to have organizational
buy-in especially from leadership
and to have all of these practices
around responsible ai
built into the metrics or key
performance indicators and so on that
they're getting judged on
so that people actually get credit for
this type of work
they also felt it was crucial to adjust
these processes to fit their existing
workflows and processes that they
already have
so this is all really eye-opening for me
because when we started the data sheets
project my collaborators and i had this
grand
but somewhat naive and retrospect vision
that we would have questions around data
and this would be the right set of
questions for everyone to answer
and we would create a nice template for
these and kind of be done with it
but in reality there are almost never
one-size-fits-all solutions for this
type of process
and in addition to figuring out how to
get the incentives right for different
groups
we need to figure out how to help teams
adapt processes
like data sheets to their own needs
these are questions that i'm really
interested in and things that the
partnership on ai is thinking about
quite actively too
okay i think we have time for one more
question
so uh given the results of the final
study i talked about
what do i recommend for data scientists
who actually want to
use intelligibility tools today
another good question um so
i actually think that the existing tools
like interpret ml
can be really valuable and useful to
data scientists
as long as the people using these tools
exercise appropriate caution
and skepticism so we've seen in our
study
that data scientists can end up placing
too much
trust in a model simply because they've
been provided with an explanation of its
predictions
and this is something we want to avoid
but there are ways that these tools can
be used to help data scientists
figure out when they should be skeptical
and i've seen data scientists use these
tools
in this way with great success my
colleague and collaborator rich carowana
has
countless anecdotes about times that he
he's used gams to
uncover surprising characteristics of
data sets including a real life example
that served in part as motivation for
what we did with the age feature in the
study that i talked about
one suggestion i'd make here concretely
is not to rely too heavily on any one
type of explanation
since they're all imperfect so for
example
it can be quite eye opening to run
both lime and shaft on the same data
sets and the same predictions
and compare what features they output is
important
in my own experience these can be quite
different
and this gives you a sense of perhaps
which features are more important and
also
how much trust to place in these
explanation techniques
uh but more broadly i think there is
still a bunch of really fascinating open
research questions on how to make these
tools more helpful to data scientists
and this is a line of work that i am
generally really interested in pursuing
okay um great so i think that is all we
have time for today and that is the end
of our webinar so thank you all so much
for attending
if you're interested in learning more
we've listed some great resources in the
resource list which i believe
should be on the right side of your
screen and it's also
in the emails that you received so this
resource list
includes among other things all of the
main papers that i talked about today
they did indeed make it online in time
um
yeah and i look forward to seeing how
you all go and build on this research
and
evolve the space of intelligibility and
machine learning have a great day and
thank you so much again for attending